Finish your bisque and put away
your snake, you kinky bastards,
because it's episode 3 of "American Horror Story",
and I think I just shit my pants.
The episode begins with hot Satan
finishing his interviews to determine
who is worthy of being admitted to Sanctuary.
He says he's responsible for
the seeds which will save mankind
and tells Gallant, Timmy and
Mallory that they will be saved.
Gallant feels sorry for killing his Nana, but
Langdon tells him she died peacefully in her sleep.
Then again, you can never
really trust the spawn of Satan.
He tells them that he has a
power called "Night Vision of the Soul",
in which he can look into the
places people want to keep hidden.
Mallory, looking more and more like a
kid from Whoville, is also interviewed by Langdon,
even though she's a Gray.
Langdon can sense she wants to slit
Coco's throat for how she's been treated by her.
He's also surprised to see Dinah Stevens
there. Apparently, they have a history.
She says she's not powerful enough
to stop whatever it is he has planned.
Does he know that she is
somehow related to the witches?
And if so, why would he want her to join Sanctuary?
He says,  "You're exactly the type of soul
I'm looking for to build my new world."
He's not saving them. He needs their souls.
We'll get into more of that in a bit.
We learn that Andre is Dinah's son
and that he thinks his mother is evil,
even though it was likely her who paid for
him and his boyfriend for their Outpost tickets.
Langdon tells Mallory that the rules of the old world,
the rules that were honored in the breach, are over.
This line, "the breach", is super interesting,
because it hints at a war between
the forces of Hell and either angels or witches.
But now since the world has been decimated,
new rules and new conflicts
between those forces will surely arise.
He tells her that he wants people that
will not only taste from the forbidden fruit,
but cut the fucking tree down.
"Forbidden Fruit" being the name of this episode
and a reference to the story of Adam and Eve,
the snake and apple imagery
making it even more evident.
Mallory tells Langdon that it feels like
someone is inside her, wanting to claw its way out.
She tries to leave when he stops her,
but she unleashes a power so fearsome
that it jettisons him across the room.
He retaliates by showing his true form: an old man.
Perhaps some sort of demon, or even his father, Satan, manifesting itself through him for a brief moment.
Mallory retaliates again, exploding the fireplace, igniting the room in a fireball, much to Langdon's surprise.
This is the first time all season
Langdon loses his composure.
He no longer is his usual calm self,
rather surprised at not having the answers.
He asks her, "Who are you?", and
judging by her look, she doesn't know either.
Langdon performs a satanic ritual similar to the
one Gallant saw him do in his dreams in episode 2.
He asks for power from his father,
who is likely the Lord of Hell, Satan.
He tells him that he thought he
destroyed them all, but one survived.
We're led to believe he's talking about witches,
but by the end of the episode,
we know many of them are still alive.
And with him knowing Dinah was one
of them, is Mallory something different?
Not a witch, but an angel?
She even says to Langdon, "I have no dark places."
An angel would be the most logical this season,
providing a great foil to the Satanism of
Michael Langdon and the Cooperative.
As he continues the ritual, the blood
begins to boil and snakes emerge.
Looks like they didn't come from the pipes or
ventilation shafts like Mead guessed in episode 2.
Something takes over Langdon, his eyes turn
jetblack and he says the words "Ave Satanas",
which is Latin for "Hail Satan".
In a series of kick-ass flashbacks,
we follow young Mead on Halloween,
dressed coincidentally like a robot.
At her first stop, she's given -
guess what - a forbidden fruit.
Fast forward to her first date
watching "Rosemary's Baby",
a movie about a pregnant
woman giving birth to the devil.
There's even a dude wearing devil horns in the back.
Fast forward again to her
first kill as an agent for Mossad,
the International Intelligence Agency for Israel.
Halloween seems to bring back her memories,
and if we remember from the
dates on the emails in episode 2,
Halloween is just around the corner.
We find Mead is talking to Venable,
letting her know about her being a robot,
questioning if all of her
memories were simply programmed.
She recollects one memory in particular
of taking care of a little blond boy,
but the memory is such a blur.
Is she referring to young Michael Langdon
from season one's "Murder House"?
Venable tells her Langdon can't be
trusted to take the right people to Sanctuary,
and when Mead finds out Venable
wasn't chosen to go, they concoct a plan:
Kill them all, steal his computer,
and find out where Sanctuary is.
We're finally going topside, where the pus- and blister-filled cannibals are having a beach party.
And look who it is from
episode 1: Coco's boyfriend Brock.
But something tells me she's
not going to approve of his makeover.
He asks them if they've heard of a bunker for the
rich, when he's ambushed and fights them off,
his shotgun making quick work of them.
A carriage similar to the one
Langdon came in in episode 1 rushes away.
But it can't be Langdon, since his
horses were eaten at the end of that episode.
It must be from someone else in the Cooperative.
An alarm goes off, alerting
Venable of a perimeter breach.
It's the carriage, and inside is a box.
But underneath Brock hides,
using the carriage like a Trojan horse.
In the decontamination chamber, the box is
checked for radioactivity and is deemed clean.
Inside are dozens of  apples.
Venable thinks Langdon sent them to prove to the survivors what will be waiting for them in Sanctuary.
She orders the Fist to take care of the horses while Mead offers a solution to their Langdon problem:
Hold a party and offer the poisoned apples as a gift,
killing every last person in
Outpost 3 before taking care of Langdon.
Remember, it was when Eve ate from the forbidden fruit
that she and Adam were banished from
the Garden of Eden and lost eternal life.
Topside, Brock stabs the Fist, stealing
her key card to gain access to the Outpost.
Mallory stares at the fire, questioning who she really is
as dissonant violin chords play,
similar to those found in the shining.
Venable calls an emergency meeting to announce
their Victorian ball-themed Halloween party.
With all they've been through,
they deserve a time to relax and let loose.
Gallant does Coco's hair in what has to be one of
the most outrageous hairstyles I've ever seen,
when Mallory asked if she can use Coco's
Loubs - Louis Vuitton's - to make a mask.
And if you know Coco, you know that ain't a go-go.
She thinks the party's where they'll
announce who gets chosen for Sanctuary,
and no way in hell is Mallory going to get chosen.
Mallory tells them how she made
the fire explode in Langdon's office.
Kind of like the Dark Phoenix, a reference to the "X-Men"- character Jean Grey, who has telekinetic powers.
Coco berates Mallory, telling her to prove it.
"Uh, there's a fire right there, bitch."
But Mallory can't seem to harness her power.
The party has begun and Mead brings in the
forbidden fruit, so that everyone can bob for apples.
A nod to season 1 and Zachary Quinto's character,
who prepared bobbing for apples on
Halloween in the Murder House.
Venable explains the importance of All Hallows' Eve,
when the boundary between
this world and the other thins.
Coincidentally, also the time when the boundary
between the Outpost and the outside world thins.
Bonus points if you saw Timmy's vest with the patches.
Coco dances with who she thinks is Langdon, explaining how marvelous it will be when she's taken to Sanctuary.
As a gesture of goodwill, she offers to give
him something she never gave her boyfriend.
"I'm talking about anilingus."
She brings him back to her room and sorry,
we don't get to see his radioactive penis.
Brock reveals himself and Coco feigns
happiness, saying how she's so glad to see him again.
But he's not having it and stabs her in the face.
Mead can't seem to find Coco or the Fist anywhere
and suggests to Venable that they stop their plan.
There's too many witnesses.
Venable says they must go forward, and we learn
they used the snake venom to concoct their poison.
She makes a toast to good fortune and everyone eats
before we're treated to the
American Horror Story-equivalent of the Red Wedding.
The denizens of Outpost 3 convulse,
vomiting up blood and bits of apple
'til every last one of them is dead.
Worst. Party. Ever.
Venable and Mead inspect the dead, reveling
in their victory before heading off to Langdon.
At gunpoint, they tell Langdon
they are making the selections now.
And in a cruel twist of malice,
Langdon tells her that she passed.
She'll be accepted to Sanctuary.
She instructs Mead to shoot, but
Mead suddenly turns the gun and ...
Venable is killed.
Mead's been under Langdon's control the whole time.
Not only that, he was the one who
came up with the poisoned apple plan.
We learn she was made by the
Cooperative Research and Development Department.
A prototype of a woman who
took care of Langdon as a child.
Langdon is the blond-haired boy
she referenced earlier in the episode.
But who is she modelled on?
The prevailing theory at the moment is she's based off Jessica Lange's character Constance from season 1,
the woman we see here
taking care of young Michael Langdon.
Then we're treated to the best part of
the series so far: The return of the witches.
Cordelia Goode, Myrtle Snow
and Madison Montgomery.
Cordelia breathes life into what she calls
their "sisters": Coco, Mallory and Dinah,
resurrecting them before Madison tells Mallory:
"Surprise, bitch. I bet you thought
you'd seen the last of me."
But the question remains: How
does Madison know Mallory?
And is it connected to that thing
inside her, clawing to get out?
Is it Zoe from season 3?
Potentially alluding to the spirits of Misty and
Queenie in the bodies of Coco and Dinah?
Or is it something else entirely?
Madison isn't referring to Mallory
herself but the thing inside her, the angel.
Notice also how Mallory took off her glasses after being resurrected, seemingly curing her vision problems.
If you recall from season 3 after Madison was resurrected, it cured her of her heart murmur.
And what will happen to the others?
Surely, this isn't the last we'll see of Gallant.
My guess is that since this was all part of
Michael's plan, he now has access to their souls.
So, we shouldn't count out that
he'll be doing some resurrecting of his own.
But this also calls into question the other bunkers.
Were they overrun, like Langdon and Venable said?
Or were their souls taken by him?
If the bunker they're in used to be an all-boys school,
it's possible the Cooperative is tied to the
warlocks, male practitioners of evil magic.
This would provide a foil to the
all-girls witches' coven in season 3.
So, are we looking at a battle between witches and the powers of Hell, or that of angels and demons?
Perhaps some combination of both.
We'll just have to tune in next week to find out.
Hey everyone, I hope you liked this video.
As always, I hope you'll like, subscribe, share
all that fun stuff and check out my other videos.
And don't forget:
Daddy loves you very much.